the stories of how documentaries are
germinated are always interesting maybe
it's a small story in a newspaper that
someone happens to see in your case this
was your teammate and your classmate at
Brown yes had you followed him through
the class newsletters or you kept in
touch we kept in touch but not I mean it
was very difficult to keep in touch with
Tom Katina in the bush ten years ago
there was no no way to get ahold of him
so I knew he was in Africa but I had we
had fallen out of touch so when I got an
email that that that read the subject
line was Cat Man Tom Katina needs our
help and essentially a truck that was
carrying a year's worth of supplies for
food and medical supplies was hijacked
and raided and this was right before the
rainy season so we had as a as a brown
community we put together hundred two
thousand dollars and got him a new truck
and filled it up with even more supplies
and got it up to him two days before the
rainy season so it's a very personal
thing you know for me because we bonded
on the football field and and we've kind
of stayed that way through life even
though we fall away we still have each
other's backs and then very personal how
did the light go on boom this guy is a
subject of a dog well when I that went
that was the moment when when I realized
that he was in peril that he was in a
war zone I mean I knew he was but to
hear that he was in the middle of the
the Nuba Mountains with bombs raining
around him and shelling taking place I
thought what am i doing I'm a filmmaker
I'm a documentarian why am I not why am
I not moving on this and so I reached
out to him and he said no I'm not worthy
he said no I'm not worthy I'm dull am i
I don't think I'd be you know a good I
would be good subject matter and I I had
to convince him and I did and he was
very reluctant but that's his nature
you know he's his nature is like the
Newman people very you know very humble
and and and loving but not wanting
attention so it's very typical of Tom to
do that but I'm sure glad I did it and
he's one of my greatest heroes this
film has been screened for Congress it's
been screened for the Paris mayor's
office it's been screened hugely
importantly at the Hague and in the
Italian Senate but but Jeff from the
point of view of a producer you have to
be very delicate about the POV because
if you say I'm making a film about the
sufferings of the Newman people that's
one kind of documentary but you also
don't want to say here's this white guy
who's the hero of all of this and so how
do you nuance you know selling the idea
of this and then putting together a film
that doesn't do what Tom Catina was
obviously afraid was going to happen and
I don't think it happened I think it was
so balanced and subtle well part of goes
back to when Ken first approached me
about the film the salient feature to
the story that I could tell and from a
little bit of footage that Ken showed me
was Tom Cuttino was a singular person
with a singular vocation and he had no
effect
he had no there's no pomposity to him
there was no desire to preach there was
just this guy from upstate New York who
decided to do something with his life
that was bigger than himself and it was
that altruistic aspect of him that sold
me on getting involved in the film and I
think comes through in the film so that
you just you don't see it as this great
white hope person you just see somebody
who's a human being with other human
beings
working to try to improve their lives
and you two had worked together before
so you could read each other when it
came to knowing that this was I knew a
guy who would go to Sudan and I'd be guy
who would not go you know he initially
said I don't know if that's a great idea
to do a film about a doctor in Africa
it's been done and I said let me just
sit you down and so we said wait Stanley
and Livingstone we sat down in a
Starbucks in Brentwood and I showed him
a you know a small teaser of Tom and he
took off the headphones and looked and
he said I'll do it you know I'm with you
on this because his that's Tom you know
his his heart is just it's it's
so huge and and it comes across I think
in the film and it came across in that
teaser so we're blessed to have Jeff and
this team Sarah and Randy it's a I'm
it's a collaborative effort here so
before I get to you Sarah what how did
you persuade Tom that this was it's
really not going to be just about him
and that this would be a tool for
teaching by actually showing up in the
Nuba Mountains and the other Mercy
Hospital I showed up and I prepare know
you were coming and there you were on
the threshold he knew I was coming but
he you know he wasn't sure that I would
make it and so when I actually made it
there and proved him that I wanted to
make a film about him and about the
Newman people and I proved to him that
that the story that I want to tell
included the Newman people and their
their living in harmony their and their
conflict and their plight he eventually
signed on it took me eight days while I
was there for the first three weeks
eight days to finally sit him down and
get an interview he was that reluctant
because he's got a job to do and he
doesn't want it to be about him he's
that modest he's that humble so it took
it took some persuasive talk but we
finally got him and Sarah did what you
had to work with us the editor the the
footage was just astounding and had you
seen anything like this before when you
when you began to work on this I'm
certainly not no I mean that's probably
one of the things that drew me to it
apart from Tom was um you can almost say
the travelogue aspect but it's not quite
that it's it's seeing the region and
it's seeing how the people live there
and that struck me is very unique you
know that you actually I'm not sure how
much of it we get in the film because it
does focus quite a bit on Tom but I like
the moments in the film where you do get
a sense of their life and just what the
people are like you know their that they
it really sata2 de bout then that Tom
talks about and it set the pitch for the
film that it would start with the the
attack and the fear of the attack too so
for all three with the that was
obviously a deliberate decision to sort
of metaphorically shove people out of
the airplane and put them on the ground
right away yeah we went back and forth
about exactly how to open the film there
were
options we had but but that certainly
seemed the strongest and and yeah I
think it does it does drop you in the
middle of it I mean it's one of the
reviews noted and which I was it's nice
to see things fed back to you and
reviews that you were thinking of when
you made it like it starts like a
travelogue with these pretty pictures of
chickens in the countryside and children
playing and then it turns anyway you
know that's that is the design and
that's what we were going for is to lead
you in thinking oh yes Africa I've seen
it yep there's a Hut I know those and
then it turns and that's the the moment
that Ken was looking for at the
beginning to sort of hook you in in a
sense but that's life there life there
is as I like to say it's calm until it's
not
it's beautiful there and and people as I
said get along so well and everything's
just peaceful and then it's not the
Antonovs role in or the sukhoi role in
and he'll is unleashed and so that's
what I wanted to depict in that opening
scene and we really went round around
about that because we don't want to
frighten people away we want to didn't
want it to be too graphic and have
people say I can't watch this film we
wanted them to be able to get over that
but we also wanted him to know this is
reality we also knew that we had to get
to the back end of the film mm-hmm we
didn't want to blow the big thing in the
beginning and then have to up the ante
after that right so it was gonna be that
kind of attack but it was gonna be
attack light but your crew was very
courageous in the middle crew was one
other no one would go with me so I did
most of the sound and it did a lot of
the shooting and I had three guys on the
hook here from Los Angeles once they did
a little research they decided to to
pull out so I found a guy from Nairobi
that was willing to go and by the way
when I recruited him the second time he
said hell no over my dead body I'll
never go back there so there was one
other person and myself that went in Wow
yeah Wow boy thank you to my wife for
allowing me to go Randy again the
question for the music would be
the same as about the POV that you had
to balance you could make it all new
band music if you chose to but there
were other considerations and other
aesthetics right yeah yeah and in terms
of the music I just want to say
something can I react to something else
I'm sure I'll talk about the music when
I first saw a screening of it with with
these three I was devastated I just I
just was devastated I was inspired I was
confused I mean I recognized the plight
of these people he's you know beautiful
people and the inspired efforts of the
doctor but then it makes you reflect
about your own life too and and I still
do every time I see it I think about my
own life and how how simple and easy it
is compared to these people but as far
as the music when I first saw it there's
an incredibly rich opportunity for music
because you have North Africa and you
have an intersection of North African
music which is of the African people and
then you have it's very close to Middle
East so you have a lot of influence from
the Middle East and that area it's the
same thing with the religions are all
mixed up together the dance is all mixed
up with the African and Middle Eastern
and the same thing with the music
there's influences from everything his
influence influence is also from popular
music from popular Sudanese music so in
this situation because it's a
documentary and with a very important
message the music definitely cannot get
in the way has to be understated has to
be supportive at all times there are a
few moments in the film where the music
can stand on its own where there's not
narration and then you need to have the
music say something but because of the
message and the importance of the film
the music is in a supportive way Jeff
it's hard to get financing for
documentaries and I expect the farther
you get from Los Angeles the harder it
is to get the financing but it's all a
lot of Karlsson names up there so you
know it's just this was a family
undertaking a big family support for
basically I was
fortunate enough to come on after the
money okay all right Kenwood build it so
here's an opportunity to thank again
thank all the members of your family for
each and every one thank you
it said we were blessed to be able to to
to be able to finance something like
this and it's really our passion it's my
wife Katrina I think she's out there she
she gave me a big thumbs up when she you
know heard that I wanted to do this and
as we know and documentary filmmaker
it's a labor of love and it's come back
tenfold
I'm not saying financially I'm just
saying and and what it has done and I
think we discussed this but you know the
heart of nuuma is is is primarily
responsible for the ceasefire that has
taken place we were actually able to get
the film into the hands of President
Omar Hassan al-bashir I was going to ask
if he'd seen it and so he saw it and you
know and let me just make sure I come
clean on this there are so many
organizations that are over there in
individuals that have been working
relentlessly to to expose this conflict
and to to make a difference and they
have I think we have just achieved a
tipping point so we actually were able
to get the film into into Omar Hassan
al-bashir his hands he saw it and he
reacted with shock and shame so we said
and he said I'm going to declare a
ceasefire based on on this film so it's
a pretty exciting moment for me and then
then he I was invited over to Khartoum
to interview him and that happened last
September and I got the the opportunity
to interview the villain the antagonists
of of my film which was a surreal
experience but once again you know we
built on what so many other people some
organizations had laid the brick work
when they did put the time and effort
into exposing this war atrocities well
please thank the panel for the heart of
new bike you
[Applause]